hey this is presh talwalkar can you
solve for x in the following equation
this problem was posed by srinivasa
ramanajam in the journal of the indian
mathematical society over a hundred
years ago
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
you might try and find an approximation
in a calculator a spreadsheet or
computer program
you'll get that x is equal to about
three
in fact x is equal to exactly three
let's see why
three is equal to the square root of
nine
nine equals one plus eight and eight
factors out into two times four
four can be expressed as the square root
of sixteen
we now have a square root inside of
another square root we've come to the
first iteration of this nested
radical
can we get to the next stage
well sixteen equals one plus fifteen and
fifteen factors out into three times
five
five can be rewritten as the square root
of 25 and we've come to the next
iteration of the nested radical
25 equals 1 plus 24
and 24 factors out into four times six
six is the square root of 36 and we've
come to the next stage
in fact i claim this pattern continues
indefinitely
therefore we've proved this infinite
nested radical is equal to the original
term which is three
but how do we know the pattern continues
if you take a look at the final square
root we always have the square root of a
perfect square
we want to know can we get from this
term to the next term
that is if we have the final square root
being a perfect square where the
coefficient is being multiplied by is
two less than the perfect square can we
always take that perfect square and
increment the perfect square and
increment the term that is being
multiplied by
this is true
algebraically we start out with our
original term and we expand out the
square
we can then rewrite this as four
equaling one plus three
we now factor out n squared plus four n
plus three into the terms n plus one
times n plus three
and now we write a radical where we have
the square root of n plus three squared
and this gets us to what we wanted to
prove so what any iteration we can
always get to the next stage and that
shows this pattern will continue
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch on social media at
preschoolwalker if you like this video
please check out my books their links in
the video description